I last night I ordered Thai food and I
ordered Thai food from this place sounds
like an AI conversation yes yes okay so
this I am judging you have my attention
Connor you I know you like Thai food
yeah it's a Thai man and I I had two
Thai places that I like to order from
one of them does like just the best
green curry it's just great it's a
perfect spice level the other one they
have Thai sausage which if you've never
had it it's amazing try it it's so good
yeah does it taste as much like sausage
in my mind as other stuff but it's just
filled with an ungodly amount of spice
yeah spices and they do that but their
green carrier isn't as good yeah so I'm
like oh [__] so this time I ordered from
that place with the Thai sausage I'm
kind of craving the sausage
and uh I leave a note saying hey last
time you gave me this uh green curry
there was no spice to it yeah you add
the spice please yeah
um and they did and they added
today's been a rough day for me because
I I think they definitely I literally I
put a translated into Japanese I said
can you please make it spicy last time
it wasn't uh and I think I should take
that as an insult
I do want to be that guy I tried to
frame it not like an insult but that it
would it would definitely catch their
attention to me like oh this [__] guy
fine because I wanted the spice level to
be insane yeah I was not expecting him
to jump but did they have it it was like
it went from like no spice whatsoever
for Japanese people to just
automatically extreme tie difficulty it
was like it was spicy for even Thai it
was crazy I I think it was the uh you
know if I were to see that note
um it's the it wasn't spicy enough last
time yeah last time it wasn't yeah
yeah the only reason I thought to do
this because you did this one time as
well but you wrote it in Thai right yeah
you were like hey please make it spicy
I'm Thai don't worry I'm tired
well that's the thing because I swear I
wrote it last time as well and they just
completely ignored me right I just ride
it in time I wrote it in Japanese so
that's why yeah and better this time
around Japanese too yeah they listen
they're my god well they took it as a
challenge I think they took it yeah I
think they literally were like let's
kill this man and I ate it all it's
great uh it was very spicy there I was
like yeah the kind of spicy you're like
you know when you you kill the burps
keep coming up you're like
next time I gotta be like hey where was
the chicken though it was like one bite
so next time you write that one like hey
so where's the chicken it'll just be a
whole chicken hey
challenging them and they're just like
keep upping it well now I know that
their list they're actually reading the
special instructions yeah which I
thought they would anyway but I guess
sometimes they just don't sometimes
they're like [__] you yeah I'm not
listening to yourself no this is your
damn special instructions someone named
Connor how are you with uh Vietnamese
food when you're in Vietnam because I
know I know it's Vietnamese food for
like Southeast Asian levels isn't that
spicy no I would definitely there's a
there's a tier list of spiciness when it
comes to Southeast Asia yeah and it's
from least spicy to most spicy it's
Filipino Vietnamese and then like
Indonesia Malaysia and Thailand or like
up here yeah so it's like you can choose
spiciness if you want it's like a choice
like with Filipino food but it's not
like oh with or without the spice makes
a difference like our Thailand just
removed the choice no no you will die
yeah you will get used like this is how
it works you're gonna take it away I
mean I understand why they would do it
but also I I mean I know there's history
behind it why not yeah and stuff in
spiced
but from just a modern day perspective
surely it ruins your taste buds going
anywhere else in the world you're like
man nothing is spicy anymore no okay I I
I don't agree with that just because
you [__] you actually the spice is
superior everything could be improved
with splice no I don't think that's true
uh I think Thai Cuisine especially is
just like the way it's cooked and the
way it's flavored it just pretty much
lends to having some spice yes uh and
because I don't like all spicy food I've
talked about this before like having the
you know Japanese Curry and having like
the different tears of spice and
sometimes there's a point where you just
feel like you're adding Spice in
artificially and that just like that
ruins this it's not like spice that's
integrated into the dishes like kind of
spiced on top you see the cookware she
added a new level have they added a new
level it's level 15 now do you just like
take a scoop of like the chili powder
and just like yeah it comes with the
side of like bowl of chili how bad can
it be yeah I mean I can't do 10 so kind
of temperature order it now yeah I
finally found out because of course
every Japanese YouTuber was like oh if
we ordered it right now would you try to
take a teaspoon I'll try it let's order
it that's one of the 15. Are you
seriously let's do it
we'll get a small we'll get a small
we'll just I want to see how bad it is
how bad could it be all right it's
pretty bad I wasn't expecting to die
today no no it's a little bit it's just
a Cocoa Tree they they do one to ten and
the ten is it's pretty bad actually it's
I don't know I don't know
okay mind you just just for reference
this is how we keep it all hooked as
well
for reference my the the comfortable
level for me is level three right right
and I've tried level four because
because and you know that's a glob
considering me you've done well yeah
you've done well I used to I used to
think level one was like
thank you yeah because that was my other
concern yeah like I used to I'd say like
before these guys move it jumps from 10
10. uh hopefully I'm not showing
anything it jumps from 10 just to 15.
there's no like
this
by 15. yeah I'm ordering yeah but like
for reference like before these guys
move to Japan I was not as used to
eating spicy food yeah um or you know I
couldn't handle it as well it's only
thanks to like me eating spice food with
these guys and just doing like you know
like the spicy Ramen and like the ghost
pepper and [__] that I've had to do for
video has definitely helped me having
just one Ghost Pepper in your life
reframes like spice for your body yeah
it like makes you re-evaluate what a
jalapeno means yeah yeah jalapenos used
to be like oh spicy to like oh this is a
nice garnish yeah I could I I legit
couldn't even like eat a habanero I love
having it yeah I remember a video of you
eating a habanero and you're just dying
oh yeah I remember back then I was like
jalapenos were like my Max but I could
go to I'll tell you about I told you
that one time I made like chili with uh
ghost pepper right yeah yeah or what
when I did that I I don't know if I told
this on the podcast but I basically put
two ghost peppers in because I thought
for like a batch of chili of like eight
people yeah like I would be time it
would level out yeah it would level out
it didn't have to happen like that and I
gave some to my housemate and she was
just dying she was like bright red be
like yeah a little bit of spice too I
was like yeah a little bit I had two
Peppers ghost peppers
see the thing the thing I you know as a
Thai person I when when I like spice I
want chilies I want fresh chilies I
don't like so much like chili sauce I
don't like you know donkey in a [__] ton
of chili sauce I want like the fresh
chilies I want to see the chili seeds in
the dish that I'm cooking because to me
that gives a much more like that fresher
kind of like spice like feeling uh
that's not kind of like artificial like
if I have like too much chili sauce it
just upsets my stomach I feel like but
that's the thing right it's like you
know when I had the ghost pepper right I
completely understand you know the whole
concept of adding like Chili Peppers or
like ghost peppers into a dish right
because the the spice complements the
Baseline flavor with the dishes
with a lot of like Thai food for example
and like Vietnamese food like yeah I can
totally see why this is necessary but
when I had the when I had the ghost
pepper on stream it was like the ghost
pepper itself doesn't really have flavor
yeah in my opinion it's like I ate into
bell pepper but it had gunpowder inside
of it yeah like it's like there's no
like yeah this is delicious the only
flavor is just pan yeah it's just pain
well that's like when I did that do the
one chip challenge and I thought it was
just like it can't be that bad because
people do it yeah and I thought you know
if it's really bad people wouldn't be
doing it that one was pretty [__] bad
that was like I think it was Carolina
Reaper and that one was like it tasted
like two of them yeah if it's just one
chip I assume it's going to be the
spiciest pepper yeah it's so [__]
concentrated yeah I'm good dog yeah
ain't it that's just so let's just
[__] take pure capsaicin or whatever
it's called you know let's uh let's call
up Nigel and just be like [__] it's pure
sport that'll be the next core my
stomach hurts thinking about this
quickly she's coming I still haven't
recovered from this Thai food yeah you
know I wanted to have a good